tu as par exemple l'histoire de cette
dame qui a démissionné du FN parce
qu'elle s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
des racistes parmi les militants
j'accueille maintenant gaz par Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
c'est un moment assez important nous
sommes le 9 novembre c'est une date
vraiment très importante enfin pour
l'Allemagne parce que c'est un 9
novembre qui a été proclamé la
République de Weimar qui a échoué le
putsch Dominique et la chute du mur de
Berlin c'est vrai en France le seul truc
qui soit arrivé à 9 novembre c'est la
naissance de David Guetta et Jennifer
[Applaudissements]
c'est à ce genre de détail que tu dis
que ça sert à rien de se tirer la bourre
avec l'Allemagne
on peut pas être compétitif on peut pas
être compétitif même en histoire bon le
9 novembre c'est aussi la mort du
général de Gaulle en France comme quoi
entre perdu un de perdus
en ce moment le temps est à l'orage
c'est un peu les masses Celtes grondes
aux portes du Royaume c'est un peu
angoissant alors à tous les niveaux les
gens perdent leurs repères c'est par
exemple l'histoire de cette dame qui a
démissionné du FN parce qu'elle s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait des racistes
parmi les militants
mais enfin faut bien adhérer au FN pour
des raisons valables non mais quand même
il y a plus de soleil il y a plus de
soleil même NKM a sorti son programme
pour Paris un programme qui fait rêver
tu as la mesure phare prolongée d'une
heure l'ouverture des métros la nuit
quand même dans le métro on aura droit à
une heure de plus pour se faire
racketter merci Nathalie
alors
c'est pas c'est pas la seule idée elle
va aussi abolir la frontière du
périphérique elle est au courant que la
Seine-Saint-Denis Montreuil Saint-Ouen
ça fait partie de l'espace Schengen
non mais c'est vraiment dramatique tout
le monde est déboussolé mais moi je suis
je suis extrêmement mal j'ai perdu ma
muse
leonarda est parti oui moi cette meuf
elle a changé ma vie il y a deux
semaines on tenait quand même la famille
défouloirs idéales il y avait rien à
faire fallait juste tu vois et depuis
qu'elle est partie bam retour du racisme
ordinaire c'est mathématique ce que se
prennent en ce moment les noirs et les
Arabes c'est tout ce que se prennent
plus les robes
c'est les vases communicants alors il y
a bien eu les manifs des lycéens mais
bon c'est un fiasco bon c'est normal sur
le parcours il y avait trop de McDo et
de Starbucks alors
il pleuvait il pleuvait c'est un facteur
c'est dormait 68 il y a moi de mai
ça n'existe pas un mouvement lycéen du
mois de février novembre les manifs
c'est comme les moules il y a des mois
pour en manger
[Applaudissements]
et de temps en temps on s'envoie des
messages Facebook avec léonarda et là le
blues dans elle m'a envoyé une photo
d'un portique écotax avec la phrase mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle a de plus que moi
même Hollande depuis cette affaire c'est
devenu monsieur padball
alors jeudi dernier la Commission
européenne a déclaré qu'il y aurait plus
de croissance en France que prévu mais
avec plus de déficit et de chômage
il n'aura pas le mec qui vient
d'inventer le chômage qui résiste à la
croissance c'est plus une politique
économique c'est une maladie nosocomiale
pendant ce temps la droite Esther on
leur fait le coup de l'ex qui va revenir
Sarkozy tout ça alors il y a eu un
documentaire extraordinaire sur D8 enfin
c'est pas un documentaire on dirait
plutôt une vidéo pédagogique intitulée
le cadrage tout ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire
bon les images sont assez terribles
Sarko au téléphone pendant que Carla
joue de la guitare faites le mec il a
pas épousé un mannequin mais un concert
privé
n'aurait dit André Manoukian qui se fait
harceler par une candidate recalée à la
Nouvelle Star
mariage pour tous dans cette période un
peu terne marquée par le racisme et la
colère il y a Berrou Borlo qui se sont
dit oui beau message envoyé à la
diversité tu sais le Bernay bec qui se
tape le Ch'ti et Denis
non mais sérieusement qu'est-ce qu'on
s'en fout franchement alors leur mariage
ça m'a fait l'effet de clochards
toxicoman qui se foutent au doigt une
capsule de canette en se disant je
t'aime mais elle est où la dose
Martine Aubry se bat comme une lionne
pour que la Redoute ne ferme pas bon
c'est normal c'est affectif on se bat
toujours pour son couturier préféré
[Applaudissements]
prostitution alors ils vont vraiment
pénaliser ça va vraiment se faire ça va
faire tourner la tête de toutes les
prostituées et de voir leurs clients
prendre une amende de 1500 €, ça va avec
cette mesure tout ce qu'on va voir c'est
que les prostituées du périph vont se
prendre pour des escorts du 8e
[Rires]
automobile le PDG de Peugeot a été
cambriolé et s'est fait piquer 70 mille
euros 70 alors bon il était un peu
dégoûté parce que malgré leur présence
sur la commode personne n'a piqué les
clés de sa 406
[Applaudissements]
foot
grève voilà à cause de la taxe 75%. bon
j'ai regardé un peu la physionomie
financière de la Ligue 1 alors adjaccio
et Bastia il y a une seule personne qui
gagne au minimum un million d'euros par
an c'est l'arbitre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
technologie une application pour
smartphone pour dénoncer les actes
islamophobes ça existe alors pour
dénoncer les actes Cristiano FOB c'est
plus compliqué parce qu'en général quand
ça t'arrive tu as plus de portable
[Applaudissements]
restauration chez Coste on place les
moches au fond pour les cacher et les
beaux devant pour montrer que Dieu
s'adresse à des gens raffinés au Flunch
c'est l'inverse
[Applaudissements]
gastronomie toujours un couple meurt
après avoir mangé des champignons
vénéneux on insistera jamais assez sur
la nécessité d'une bonne hygiène intime
nous les hommes
bonne nouvelle alors on a retrouvé un
corps dans la Seine et un crâne dans la
baie d'Antibes c'est impressionnant le
réseau hydraulique français alors ma
belle et la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu